10 merci monsieur le foll la parole et à
monsieur jean claude mathis
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question auxquelles j'associe l'ensemble
de mes collègues qui travaillent sur le
sujet porte sur l'actuel mouvement des
étudiants en chirurgie dentaire qui est
comme chacun sait sont mobilisés dans
toute la france et par là même relayé
ici leur inquiétude comme vous le savez
ce mouvement et de grande ampleur
quatre semaines de grève hospitalière
95% de grévistes dans les seize faculté
de chirurgie dentaire tous les soins
dentaires dans les hôpitaux publics
arrêtés sauf dans les urgences cela avec
le soutien de très nombreux
professionnels
c'est un mouvement qui se bat pour le
maintien de la qualité des soins bucco
dentaire pour tous
c'est donc un sujet crucial de quoi
s'agit-il
les tarifs des soins dentaires n'ont
pour la plupart pas été revu depuis les
années 1980 alors même que l'inflation
perdure que les techniques de médecine
bucco dentaire ne cesse d'évoluer et que
le coût du plateau technique est en
hausse continue
les inégalités d'accès aux soins
augmente car le désengagement de la
sécurité sociale entraîne la mise en
place d'un système de santé à deux
vitesses
en effet la dernière loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale a imposé un
arbitrage à défaut d'un avenant de
signature au 1er juillet 2014 à la
convention nationale des chirurgiens
dentistes
or les négociations conventionnelles
entre les syndicats et l'union nationale
des caisses d'assurance maladie n'ayant
pas d'outil cet arbitrage est engagé sur
la base de propositions qui ne
permettent pas de réaliser des soins
selon les données acquises de la science
et ne sont pas en adéquation avec les
besoins réels des patients la france
dispose d'un des meilleurs d'une des
meilleures formations dentaire d'europe
il est donc indispensable que les cons
les tarifs conventionnés tiennent compte
de l'évolution
de l'america madame marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés et monsieur le
député mathis garantit à tous nos
concitoyens des soins dentaires de
qualité je crois que tout le monde ici
est d'accord la question qu'il faut
poser c'est à quel prix parce que en dix
ans les tarifs des soins dentaires ont
augmenté de 66 points pour ce qui est du
dépassement et il ya aujourd'hui chez
les dentistes un taux de dépassement
moyen qui est de 300 %
c'est pour mettre fin à cette dérive
qu'un certain nombre de mesures sont
aujourd'hui proposés dans la loi de
modernisation de notre système de santé
un tarif social a été proposée pour les
prothèses pour les bénéficiaires de
l'aide à la complémentaire santé
mais nous savons qu'il n'ya pas que nos
concitoyens les plus modestes qui ont
des difficultés pour se payer une
couronne ou des soins de prothèses chez
le dentiste et c'est pour cela que j'ai
proposé un plan ambitieux qui a un
objectif extrêmement précis de quoi
s'agit-il d'un côté on propose de
plafonner le prix des couronnes
dentaires des prothèses et de l'autre
comme vous semblez le souhaitez on
revalorise de manière très significative
le prix de la prévention et des soins
conservateurs
concrètement l'assurance maladie a
proposé un accord cet accord il portait
sur 800 millions d'euros et cela
représentait une augmentation des
revenus des dentistes de près de 2 de
9000 euros par an pour plus de 75%
dentiste les dentistes ont refusé et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
président du haut conseil pour
l'assurance maladie a nommé un médiateur
qui va faire des propositions dans
quelques semaines mais je vous le dit
monsieur le député je suis absolument
convaincu que le nos concitoyens et vos
électeurs sont attachés à pouvoir aller
chez le dentiste à un tarif abordable et
vous devrez expliquer pourquoi vous des
loin d'eux
le monde